Sona this is big news you're giving the
commencement speech for the Mount San
Antonio informally known as Mount Sac
College commencement I am not giving the
commencement address it's a two-minute
speech okay wait I thought you were
giving the commencement address no I'm
I'm alumna of the year for hey
congratulations congratulations I don't
like the way you said that did they
didn't it that was I was congratulating
sincerely I think that was delivered
sincerely with the understanding that an
insult was to follow yes yeah but later
like in 20 minutes okay all right okay
and unrelated to this no oh Sona I
really am honestly proud of you thank
you I'm very proud of uh you've you've
accomplished a lot and I'm I was saying
a nice thing that's nice I honestly was
it's I the way you said it was just very
I'm sorry thank you sorry sorry but it
was you had a tone
that's my nasal voice I can't help it
you're like you had a tone and your lips
were thin and your eyes were beating
yeah that's me I can't help that no but
I they they named me alumna of the year
I went to a community college before I
transferred to USC I'm very proud of my
time there and then they named me alumna
and of the year and you did a an
interview for the video they're gonna
show a commencement and I found out
recently there's gonna be like 12 000
people there 12 000 that's a big crowd
yeah that's a big crowd I know but wait
a minute you're always talking about how
you're you were speech Champion
yes yeah you bring that up all the time
every you bring that up when they pull
you over for a DUI you're like no it's
not so stupid all right you're free to
go there's some more alcohol
Hair of the Dog yeah we didn't realize
you were a national speech Champion
here's much more vodka thank you
Professor well it's officer not the
officer but I still refuse to give you a
blood alcohol test so I think you're
going to be fine do you know what you're
going to talk about yeah give us the
first line give us a little preview uh
well I'm doing it in a they built a
brand new stadium that we're gonna have
the graduation in did you say I was I
thought you were gonna say I'm doing it
in an accent no no no they built this
brand new stadium at the school so my
first line is thanks for building this
stuff
I like that that's great it's stupid but
there's not like a lot of jokes it's not
like oh you gotta have jokes will you
write it for me well you've done you've
done I won't write them for you all
right because there's a writer's Guild
strike so I refuse to help you with this
well I thought and I hope you bomb go
wga yeah you producer you ruthless
I thought you couldn't write shows and
stuff you could write a commencement
address I think I can it's a you know
you're real it's not Union at all it's
me it's just a two-minute speech you're
the man you're the man now you know what
you are I'm sick of your boot on my
throat yeah you've written two why don't
you get AI to write it yeah I
know I should you should get AI you've
written two of like really well-known
commencement addresses that were like
longer than two minutes can I borrow
from your from your Harvard class Day
speech or Dartmouth address no you
cannot hey Sona think of all the amazing
things in life that are expressions of
just you yeah I mean like the chocolate
that you had on your face when you came
in because you just ate that what was it
you were eating I was eating a giant
cookie giant cookie yeah and that's so
Sona okay or that song you stream over
and over again it's just so you what's
that song For You Twinkle Twinkle Little
Star yeah but it's for my boys I know
still it's nice okay or you know that
podcast that comedy podcast you just
gotta listen to yeah Conan O'Brien needs
a friend exactly is that what you listen
to in your spare time yeah love it
everything that makes you you makes all
the difference State Farm believes
Insurance should work the same way your
plan your coverage selections can be
personalized by you and only you that's
cool I shouldn't shout but this is how
strongly I feel about it you go to
choose a plan you want by picking the
options that fit you like choosing to
bundle your home and auto policies is
what the State Farm personal price plan
is all about getting the coverage you
want at an affordable price just for you
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customers availability and
eligibility may vary how much time did
you say you have two minutes you don't
there's no such thing as a speech that's
two minutes long that's that's uh are
you sure they're being square with you
you're not just introducing someone no
but there's there's a three minute video
and then there's a two minute I get five
minutes I'm I'm just first of all a
little blip can I say something they say
two minutes but you're gonna take more
than two minutes because there's no such
thing as a two minutes speech oh why I
wrote it that's called ordering a pizza
okay you know not a bad idea yeah but
still that's why
I just take stuff that you wrote
um well it won't match okay uh you know
tourism well but also it just won't
match your personal experience you come
from you have such a different
background than me and you have a great
story to tell coming to this country oh
come on
um uh a boat that you made out of brillo
pads sewn together with beeswax that had
been dried and turned into twine
you forged a path across a Mighty Sea
you have a great story to tell and also
what I think is very cool and I'm being
sincere here is you know this you
started this community college and look
what you've achieved I think that's
that's very cool it is and I'm shocked
because there's a lot of really
impressive alumni that have come out of
there so when they first said I was the
alumn of the year I was like I was like
why who are they are there anyone we'd
know no oh
honest with you though though I think
it's I think it'll be an inspiration for
all of them yeah to see you because you
do have a lot of fans and you are an
impressive person and I think I I and
I'll tell you I think it's also
you know
um good for these people to see your I
think you're still able to connect to
young people I think you're a very
youthful person so it's not that's not
you're not a stodgy old person saying
now let me tell you something when I was
a boy you know yeah first of all you
shouldn't say when you were a boy
because because you weren't but uh but I
think it's gonna go really well I've got
thank you I've gone back to Mount Sac a
few times to talk to the students and I
can't tell you how many people uh love
you which I was surprised I'd say that
these are educated people well
she says people no she means some of the
farm animals hanging out they're young
in the agricultural lab they're super
young and they're like not that you know
I I know I'm like saying I just I always
think that they're just like into like
Taylor Swift and like Billy eilish and
like yeah they cross over between my
fans and Billy eilish fans and uh Taylor
Swift fans I'm convinced of that no yeah
yeah just because you convinced yourself
doesn't mean that it's true on her
current tour Taylor often starts the
show by saying how many Conan fans we
got in the crowd and the place erupts oh
okay I've not seen any footage of that I
haven't seen it either
um and I haven't even heard about it but
I'm pretty sure it's happening because
of my power to deceive myself is
absolutely incredible that's impressive
co-nifties yeah
how Nifty excuse me what's that a Taylor
Swift fan who's often who's also a Conan
O'Brien fan okay how many uh are there I
said
I'm the co-nifty yeah that's what it
should be yeah are you vegan you know
what it's like this rare bird that no
one's seen in a thousand years are you
the
someone who loves
that Fringe weirdo
they photoshopped a picture of the two
of you like just together hanging out
yeah so cool uh well I'm when is it
happening it's happening very soon well
it by the time the audience hears this
it will have already happened on June
9th so do you get to wear a gown and a
Mortar Board yeah that's nice I know
that's gonna be cool you get a special
like scarf of some kind of like a Nexium
I have no idea are they gonna give you
any kind of
doctorate you can get a doctorate come
on I don't know you got an honorary
doctorate I'm not sure I think from
Dartmouth they said something I don't
know I don't know I'm not being koi I
honestly don't know they put something
around my we got to look up what I got
I'm pretty sure he got a doctorate yeah
but I know that it was I wanted it to be
an oral surgeon
I wanted to actually be a doctor
afterwards and then be able to open up
[Laughter]
author of Arts
I'm
a doctor of art come on
is there a doctor I wish next time I'm
in an airplane and something happens is
there a doctor here hello
I am a doctor of Arts
from Dartmouth and I'm gonna push my way
to the front well this person should be
having a heart attack have you got a
book
maybe Factory
or one of the Bronte sisters care to
talk about the contrapposto of the
statue David
because on those matters I'm good to go
he's dead he's dead he died while you
were talking about the brontes well I
did what I could I suppose that makes me
some kind of hero excuse me I'm an
actual doctor and I couldn't get up here
because this was blocking the
aisle I'm actually a pulmonary
specialist I could have saved this man
by doing chest compressions that's all
well and good
but I got here first because I'm a
doctor of the Arts well all right let's
wrap it up gang congratulations
congratulations to those students and
you know what my advice to you is enjoy
it that's a moment
when you're up there take it in and
don't you have a tendency to go oh no uh
take it in that's a really nice moment
be they'll be thrilled that you're there
and enjoy it and we're really proud of
you oh that's very cool thanks guys